اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر موانئ البحر
الاسود الاوكرانيه موضع نقاش الاسبوع
المقبل في نيويورك بين وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجيلافروف والامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو في الاثناء تحذر موسكو من
ان التوقعات بشان تمديد اتفاق الحبوب بعد
الثامن عشر مايو ايجار ليست كبيره جدا
عازمونا على تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق بالكامل اذ
نواصل بعزم العمل على الجزء الاخر من حزمه
المساعدات عبر تسهيل تصدير الحبوب
والاسمده المخاطر المتعلقه بذلك كبيره جدا
توصلت بولندا واوكرانيا الى اتفاق بشان
استئناف عمليه نقل الحبوب بعد تعليقها يوم
السبت
لا يمكننا الذهاب في اي اتجاه لن تسمح لنا
بولندا بالدخول واضح ان هناك مشكله لا
نعرف ما هي
هذا الانسداد هو نتيجه للقرار الاحادي
الذي اتخذته وارسو بحذر استيراد وعبور
الحبوب والمنتجات الزراعيه الاوكرانيه
الاخرى حتى الثلاثين من شهر يونيو المقبل
وهي الخطوه نفسها التي اتخذتها المجر
وستوفاكيا في شهر مايو 2022 علق الاتحاد
الاوروبي الرسوم الجمركيه لمده عام واحد
على جميع المنتجات المستورده من اوكرانيا
بهدف دعم اقتصادات دوله لكنه سمح لاحقا
بتصدير مخزونها من الحبوب بعد اغلاق الطرق
البحريه على البحر الاسود استمر القمح
والذره وعباد الشمس في الوصول بكميات
كبيره الى الدول المجاوره حيث تظل مخزنه
في الصوامع لان الحبوب لا تتدفق بسرعه
لاسباب اللوجستيه وفي مواجهه الوفره بدات
الاسعار المحليه في الانخفاض ما اثار غضب
المزارعين في بولندا